hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
fast typing and classification of
streptococcus pneumoniae and hygiene
relevant strains
i'm alexis krauss of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths and
sponsored by
broker deltonics for more information
about our sponsor
please visit their website at
brooker.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr stefan zimmerman
had a division excuse me head of
division bacteriology
department of infectious diseases at the
university hospital of heidelberg
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr zimmerman
you may now begin your presentation
thank you very much for this uh nice uh
introduction and
uh welcome uh everybody to the
today uh brooker seminar
my uh talk will be about the ir biotype
3.0 and it's a fast strain
typing for real time epidemiology
and uh before i start with my talk
let me briefly introduce our hospital
you see the picture here it's located at
the bend of the river
neca in the beautiful city of heidelberg
our university hospital is one of the
biggest german university
hospitals with 2 400 beds
about 250 of these beds are
located at the icu and our lab is a
microbiology
lab and we don't have a 24
7 service like in
many north american labs we only have a
12 day shift and seven days per week
so the size of our lab we have about 26
full-time technicians and about five
microbiologists and
we handle about eight hundred two
thousand specimens
per day in the bacteriology lab
but uh the topic of my talk today is
fourier transform
infrared spectroscopy what is that
so joseph fourier was a mathematician
in the late 18th beginning of the 19th
century and
he developed a lot of new
formulas for trigonometric functions
and uh finally developed what is called
the
decomposition the fourier transformation
and this decomposes a function of time
into the frequency that makes it up and
this technology was used for infrared
spectroscopy you know the visible
part of light is roughly between 200 and
700 nanometers of wavelength
and then above that uh there comes the
infrared
light with 700 nanometers to one
millimeter
and i just start for those of you
who don't have an ir bite or typo
already with the
quite simple workflow of this instrument
i use the
example of pneumococcus you see on the
left upper picture typical morphology of
saprococcus pneumoniae on a blood agar
plate and you just
pick some of these colonies and
transfer them on a silicon
plate you put this silicon plate into a
frame and load it
load it into the instrument and then the
ir biotyper does all the rest so
it records an infrared absorption
spectrum
between 700 and 4000
nanometer of wavelength and then the
software part and the analytics of the
instrument
starts and for the pneumococcus
most important is the carbohydrate
region
of the air transform spectra which is
located between 800 and 1 300
nanometers and what you can see here the
instrument does a hierarchical
clustering and clusters together several
capsule types of pneumococcus
the workflow when you do analysis for
infection control
or for salmonella
sterotyping for example it's a little
bit different though you also have your
cultured isolates
probably on plug blades or on
different aegas and
then you make a suspension
after a growth time of 18 to 24 hours
you do a suspension
of your cultured material in a
mix from water and ethanol and
you have this pre-prepared app and off
cups
from uh the ir biotype kit which
contains
four metal uh cylinders and
uh these are for the disruption of the
bacteria
and for their producing a very
homogeneous
suspension of the bacteria while you
robotic
vortex the the append of cups which only
takes
a few minutes and then you use a pipette
to do your technical replicates on the
silicon
sample plates we usually do triplicates
but you also
can use four or five technical
replicates
we use triplicate and then you put the
silicon sample
plate in the frame and load it into the
ir
biotyper
and uh if you have a fully loaded plate
with 96
uh spots then it takes the ir bio type
about an hour maybe less to analyze
96 spots
well and i will come to the first
routine application
which will be serotyping of pneumococci
and
sarmonella this is a quite a complex
procedure if you do it in the routine
lab and
you may ask the question why uh why is
this necessary to know the capsule type
of
planimococci in a clinical microlab
first not all capsule types of
pneumococcus with
different capsule types have the same uh
viral lens so some are more pathogenic
uh than
than others and uh some uh types like
the zero
type 15 for example is known to be often
multi-resistant for example in asia
and a spanish research group has
recently
published that for example the capsule
type 8
frequently induced osteomyelitis so if
you
know the capsule type of pneumococcus
you have isolated
from a patient sample you
can do a kind of risk analysis if this
may induce it may be a capsule type
which may induce osteomyelitis uh
or not and uh of course you all know
uh last but uh not least that uh we have
two uh pneumococcal vaccines
the pediatric ones covering
13 different capsule types and the adult
vaccine covering
23 different capsule types so
not all of the known 92 pneumococcus
capsule types are covered by vaccine and
this might be
also important to know when you have an
outbreak for example if the strain
you deal with can be protected
by vaccination or or not
but before we started
to build up a database
for pneumococcus on the ir
biotype
we had to do some work and
check if they're the influence of the
medium
and the incubation time for our
pneumococcus
strains and you see the results here on
the left
you can see that there are slight
differences
when you use different blood agars from
different
companies so
and also in the right panel you see that
their
uh the incubation time
how long the pneumococcus was
incubated before the analysis
uh give a slight difference so if you
have
in light green the 16 hour and in light
blue the 24 hour
incubated strain so you see the
difference here on
on this slide so what we did before
building up our
database we established a strict uh
protocol
about the area we use and the incubation
time
before we put strains into
our database
and then we wanted to know if we get
a reliable spectra from the ir biotyper
but
we had a great results you see some five
technical replicates
an atcc pneumococcus strain in the left
panel and you see this
really cluster quite closely
together and then to make sure that
there's no shift in the database
and in the strengths reload we did
biological replicates
over 20 weeks we measured the same atcc
pneumococcus 19f strain
every week over 20 weeks and you see
all these bars they cluster really
closely together so there's
no shift over time so it's really
reliable
if you have your database and you
challenge it with a strain
one year or two year later that you get
the same results as in the
beginning
and i already mentioned the two
pneumococcal
vaccines the pneumococcus conjugate
vaccine with 13 different capsule types
a pediatric one
and a polysaccharide vaccine
for adults with a 23 different capsule
type in the in the right panel and
what we did we loaded several of these
13
or respectively 23 capsule types in our
database and you see the biotype are
really
greatly cluster them
together and now as we have
a database with more than 60 different
capsule types we don't have yet all 92
capsule type but we have more than 60
different capsule types
included and what we now can
do with the biotype and with our
database
if we have a routine isolate
from a recent sample from the routine
lab
then uh we can load it into the biotyper
you see the
uh challenging uh
strains are the the pink ones and uh in
the
left panel you see this was a zero
type one uh strain which nearly
clustered between
the other serial type bond strains here
in
green bars and in the second example on
the on the right
panel we had a serial type 11 a strain
and again the challenge strain from the
routine lab
is in pink and this nicely clusters to
the
11a cluster and of course we checked
that by
pcr and by our analysis
with the neufeld clelons reaction from
our national reference center which
confirmed
that the biotyper results were correct
so as i just uh mentioned the neufeldt
kralong reaction currently is called the
gold standard
of pneumococcus capsule
typing and irene burkhart gave me this
nice uh slide so the neufeld kralong
reaction is done
by rabbit anti-seria against different
pneumococcus capsule types but
what you can do with an antibody which
binds to the surface of the pneumococcus
you only can see the surface
here of this nice and beautiful
rose but when you do a
ir biotype analysis this is like a
magnetic
resonance imaging so you really get a
whole picture from outside
and inside of this beautiful rose it's
not colored it's black and white but it
gives you much
more data than the the neufeld uh
quellon's
reaction and the more on data
the more on peaks on the is on the one
hand but
on the other hand uh it's also much
faster so if we have a pneumococcus
isolate let's say from a meningitis
case from cerebral spinal fluid or from
a sepsis
with pneumococcus with a isolate from
blood culture
we send that to the national reference
lab for
the north eltrellons reaction and this
takes about roughly
four weeks if we do the ir biotype
analysis in our lab this time to result
is one to two days
depending if we need a subculture
on a blood agar for 20 hours or if
we already have that so there's a huge
time advantage with the biotype in our
lab for
typing of pneumococcus strength
and i was asked a little bit today about
the new
3.0 software for the io
ir biotyper because it really has some
new
and exciting features one of them is a
3d
scatter blot and
what we did here we loaded 110
steptococcus pneumonia isolates from
26 different uh serotypes and then with
a new
software you can based on a linear
discriminant
analysis you can get this uh very
beautiful
3d scatter plots so you have here these
clouds of
different capsule types in different
colors so this is more art than science
but it really gives you a high
discrimination between the different
uh capsule type and is one of the
features
these 3d scatter plots which is new in
the in the
3.0 software version
so there are other
new uh things in the in the in the
software version
they are called classifiers and
artificial
neural networks so
it the 3.0 uh software
offers additional tools for real-time
strain
typing so you can have your training set
of known strains
isolates or serotypes and
these are used to build a statistical
model and
then this supervised model there you can
correct a single data
points can be used for classification of
unknown
samples as i've just shown you for the
pneumococcus and then we have a kind of
machine
learning algorithms this artificial
neural
networks and these are innovative
bioinformatic
tools to generate these classifiers so
it's a very clear workflow you
as an input you do your training data
set of known samples
then you have this machine learning this
algorithms
learns to recognize the known ones and
then you have the output as a
classification of unknowns
and the example i've just shown you was
for the pneumococcus
zero typing
and you have also a new
display using some traffic light
codes in green yellow and red
so here you have an one of these
artificial networks trained with 95
pneumococcy
isolates of 26 different serological
groups and then on the right side then
we applied 105 other
mean so called uncharacterized
isolates put them in this
uh analysis and uh then
we get in green uh the the
good uh identifications for streptococci
of a certain
capsule type and if we have a yellow
result these results must be issued with
caution so green means the sample is
located within the spectral space of the
training set
yellow means the outlier score is
between the inlier and the outlier
threshold so
the threshold is below 2.0 so these
results are probably correct but must be
viewed
with caution and then if you have
red results this means that the
result the outlier score is beyond the
outlier threshold and the
the isolate probably does not belong to
any known
class and in the example here on the
panel uh we used streptococcus gordoni
uh isolates uh which of course were not
classified
in a training set which was done to type
streptococcus uh
pneumoniae capsule type so this really
works nice and gives clear-cut results
uh i don't want to bore you with this
old
slide this was shown by professor
burkhardt on a broker user meeting
two years ago and we had this idea of
capsule typing for pneumococci but
already two years ago we had uh we were
speculating about
a future perspective how to use the ir
biotyper and one of our ideas was
salmonella because
the o antigen of salmonella also
uh is is made from polysaccharides as a
capsule of
pneumococcus and it's the same with
meningococci
and in the routine lab you also do a
stereotyping of meningococci of course
if it's
uh zero uh capsule type a
b uh or c4 for example
and uh we also speculated if it would be
possible also to type a legionella
especially the highly uh
viral and ligonella pneumophila
zerova one so these were future
perspective and
uh let's see uh what happened uh within
the
uh two years uh since this user meeting
and uh the one who picked up the idea of
the salmonella
stereotyping was miriam cordovana from
bologna and she really did
great work and also a lot of work
because she put 90 uh
serotypes of salmonella in terrica
belonging to 23 different zero groups
into a database and you see quite
similar
in the left panel quite similar
graphs uh as we had them with epinema
caucus and
true zero groups were depicted
each one in a different color so
in this color bar going from red over
green and blue
so each serial type has its own
color and then when you analyze this uh
data set
for the salmonella serogroup typing with
a new 3.0 software you again
get this three dimensional
scatter plots where every zero group has
a different
color and uh
so when you uh look in this in in detail
you
uh you are able to uh oh
zero type uh salmonella so oh two or
four five or nine and you all know of
course
salmonella typhi belongs to the o9
zero group and uh within the o nine
uh zero group uh there's a second
classifier so you can also distinguish
between salmonella typhi and other 09
0 types of salmonella which of course is
very useful for the routine
diagnostic if you have salmonella and
the blood culture and
you get the result oh this is o9 you of
course
wanted to know if this is salmonella
typhi and typhoid fever or if this is
a more enteric salmonella from the o9
type and
you see this 3d scatter plot
here and there were two white groups
which were previously unknown
isolates which were analyzed on the ir
biotyper
and then these machine learning
algorithms these artificial neural
networks were applied in the software
analysis
and you see these ones
clearly cluster within several
clouds in this 3d scatter plots
and uh so you see here that this one
belongs uh to this
uh serial type and
uh with this new software and the
database
miriam set up so
it's now possible to
automatically classify an unknown
salmonella
isolates with the ir biotyper and the
provided software
and when you use this o group classifier
as it's uh
called you again have this traffic light
coding green again is is uh
a classification you absolutely can
trust on
and if your ir biotype that tells you
this
is an uh 09 in green or this is
o7 or in the bottom
04 then you can absolutely trust that
if the result is o2 for example in
yellow
then you may have to repeat the analysis
or even maybe you can confirm it
by agglutination reaction
but normally the database really greatly
works and you can
do your salmonella typing with the ir
biotyper
and as we had the example with the
streptococcus
goldeneye for the pneumococcus database
when you
apply a klebsiella pneumonia here in the
bottom line of course you get a red
result because because
of course capsule lab pneumonia
does not
cannot be grouped within the salmonella
or serotypes
so uh when typing uh of salmonella
and the the differentiation within the
o9 uh serial type
so you have the sub
group typing here for
for typhi uh in the in the in the
at the bottom and other 09 uh
salmonella types are on top so
the biotype biotyper software and the
algorithms are already
able to do a subtyping within the 09
group and you see here salmonella
javiana for example is 09 but
non-typhy or salmonella
salame is also correctly grouped as
o9 but not typhy and then you have three
salmonella typhi
which are identified correctly so
this really helps if you have a blood
culture isolate for example
so and there's just a second classifier
was developed
and applied to the software who
differentiates
within the o9 group salmonella typhi
from other stereotypes
and i think most of you
in the audience are using mass
spectrometry
for identification of bacteria in the
routine
clinical micro lab and so
you're all familiar with the multi
biotyper for identification
and now with the new software version
with the 3.0 software
version it's also possible to
mate you a multi-biotype to the ir
biotyper software so it's kind of
coming together and you can
import data from the maldi into the ir
biotype either directly or
via the lab information system
and so you can import the isolate
information of the identified species
into the ir biotyper and then set up the
ir biotyper run
for further analysis
and a nice uh
example uh for that is the so called
legonellapneumophila01
classifier so you get the identification
from the mali that this is legonella
pneumophila and then
you move on from the maldi biotyper to
the ir
biotyper and further analysis
there and do an analysis with this
legonella classifier and then get the
information okay
this legionella pneumophila
is a 01 and as i already mentioned
this is highly
uh virulent uh and uh it's always
uh good uh to know uh uh
if your legionella identified in the
maldi uh
is a zero one uh strain so
and uh
so this is easy to understand and
fulfill the really this user's
requirement and uh when you think back
on our future perspective from the user
meeting in 2018 we
already within this short time of two
years
there was a solution uh provided for the
salmonella
serial typing and also for the legonella
serotyping and if you in your lab have a
huge
uh collection of uh many gocoxie
you may be the one who do the menigo
cocci
uh database and uh classifier so as we
do not have
enough meningococcus strains in our lab
so outlooks and benefits for the new
software classifiers and artificial
neural
networks the classifier approach opens a
new dimension for routine work it's a
real time
analysis and you can build your own
classifiers
it's easy to use the tool to get a
definitive answer for unknown
classifications
there's an easy interpretation by color
coding and scoring
and fast answers as soon as spot is
measured
the classification result will be
displayed
on the ir biotyper as you already know
it from the multibiotype
so there's this color coding
and that i will switch
from the typing of
specific strains to to another field uh
where the ir biotyper can be used and
this is a
infection control so for hospital
hygiene
applications you can do epidemiology and
outbreak analysis with the ir biotyper
and we in heidelberg had the first
german outbreak for klebsiella
pneumonia containing a klebsiella
pneumonia uh
carbopenemys the kpc this was in uh 2008
and at that time
we did our outbreak analysis with
pfge analysis here seen in the left
panel and
when we had the i o bio type
in our lab we went
to the fridge and put out these old
outbreak
strains and analyze that with the ir bio
type
and you see this very nice and colorful
clustering here the
purple strains and the light purpose
transits for the control strains and in
green
and in light green
we had the outbreak strains and these
two subgroups from the outbreak we also
confirmed
with next generation sequencing that
this was one
outbreak but with two closely related
sub types so this is completely seen
also in the ir biotype
analysis and to give you some examples
from uh different
uh species of multi-resistant
gram-negative
we had this patient coming to
our hospital this is the original
patient's report
i apologize uh that is of course in
german so this was a scrotal
swab taken from this patient and we
found a high amount of this ac
acnetobacter
baumanii which was not only
multi-resistant
but indeed was pan resistant and of
course we said in the report that
infection control measures
has to be applied for example barrier
isolation
for this patient and
this strain was detected in our lab two
days
after the patient entered our hospital
so these pump resistant acinetobacter
already was spread to three uh other
patients and this
is uh overview about the outbreak
analysis so
uh we received 100 more than 150
additional samples
over the weekends from contact
patients to that and
this was in 2012 as you see in the
headline at that time we don't have an
ir biotyper so
we try to do rapid outbreak analysis
with our broker mbt microflex
we put in all these samples calibrated
them
and build a dendrogram as well as a
composite correlation index
were calculated and using the broker
software for the multi
biotype and what you see here the
control
strains in light blue and top and the
outbreak
strains with this pun resistant async an
asymmetrobacter clustered together
by this smiley analysis and again when
we
got the ir biotype we
went back to these old outbreak strains
and
uh you see here that uh all the
acinetobacter bombani
strains they cluster closely together
here in
orange color by the negative control
strains they are
in green so this outbreak analysis
with the ir biotyper here was as good as
a next generation sequencing
and as a last example an outbreak with
pseudomonas aeruginosa
which happened a few years ago in our
surgical
hospital so we had different isolates
and
liver asparagus asparagus
one isolate two isolates from bile uh
from and uh again control uh
pseudomonas isolates from rectal swabs
or whatever so
uh the outbreak strains here in green
and they
control isolates in
in purple and you see again that the
ir biotype are correctly grouped and
clustered
these outbreak strains and as mentioned
here with the light green there was one
which was a little bit
apart this was this liver isolate but
all the other really closely clustered
together in the ir biotype
analysis and
uh jan lieser from the infection control
team of the university hospital in
uh tubing and he also used the ir bio
type and did a lot of work
with typing of gram negatives for
infection control
purposes and he published that in the
jcm
two years ago this is the example of
typing and identification of eclipse
yellow out break
and you have a next generation
sequencing
results on the one hand and on the other
hand you have the
uh f theory the biotype
analysis and again similar results
between the
whole generation sequencing and the
biotype
analysis for that and uh
so this was uh jan's first work uh
dealing with fabziella and
uh one year later so in november 2019 he
also
published that the outbreak analysis for
enterobacter
clerk strengths was possible
and gave
a similar results for the i o bio type
as for next generation
sequencing so i may say that
biotype is really approved for infection
control
and outbreak analysis for gram negatives
so another more research uh project uh
in our lab uh
was we were looking for viral lens uh
factors of arcobacter butzleri you may
know arcobacter butsler is closely
related to campylobacter but what we
found out in a
huge analysis that not all arcobacter
butcher restraints
induced diarrhea in the patients which
were colonized
so we were looking for or searching for
specific virulence
factors for the diarrheal strains
and there were some outbreaks with
archobacter butslory so it's also called
an emergent enteropathogen
and what we find out when we did a
antibiotic susceptibility test for
all our aquabacter strains that there
was a
specific multi-resistant or
pun resistant strain you see always on
the right side of the analysis
so highly resistant to doxycycline some
were highly resistant to erythromycin
and of course all archiboxa strains are
resistant to
kefor taxim but some are really uh
highly resistant to careful toxin with
mic greater than 256
microgram per mill so
we wanted to know if these
multi-resistant
strains are clustering and what we did
together with york rao in stuttgart
we did a cluster analysis using the
the ir biotyper and you see here these
results of different
archobacter but bootslovery isolates
from our labs and on the right
side of the panel you see the resistance
susceptible or resistance and then
we did the analysis with the ir biotyper
and this revealed a clustering of the
multi-resistant
strains so the pun resistant strains
resistant to tetracyclines macrolides
and
fluoroquinolones they clustered here in
in one cluster as a ce1 and c2
cluster while the
tetracycline and macrolide resistant but
fluoroquinoline
fluoroquinolone susceptible strains say
clustered differently in in the
subcluster e
so this helped us uh we have a
collection of more than 220 acrobacter
butler restraints meanwhile and we have
dude we do not have the kappa
capacity currently to sequence them all
so this really helps us to pick the
strains
we use for whole genome sequencing to
find this viral lens
factors and resistance factors within
the echobacter community so this is
really helpful as a yeah kind of
pre analysis for
for next generation sequencing also
so uh to sum up uh for the ir biotype
version 3.0
this offers a possibility to connect the
multibiotyper to the ir biotyper this is
this really beautiful 3d
scatter plots which gives you
clouds of differently colored
pneumococcus capsule types or
salmonella o types
it has an improved graphical
user interface which is easy to use
an improved usability with easy
reporting for example as a pdf
run report you now have in the version
3.0 the full wave number range from
800 to 4000 nanometers of wavelength
and as i've shown you in detail you have
the possibilities who set these
classifiers for pneumococcal
serial grouping for salmonella typing
for lagonella
typing and we said i wanted to
conclude biotype is a new and promising
technology for stereotyping of
pneumococcal it is a fast and less
laborious as many
conventional methods the ir biotype
results are highly reliable and
discriminatory we have good results for
pneumococcus
typing for the vaccine strains
it's very reliable as i hopefully have
shown you for the salmonella oh
serotyping and the subtyping of the o9
group
is a promising tool for rapid and
reliable outbreak
analysis it showed good concordance with
other typing methods
like wrapped pcr next generation
sequencing or pulse field
jail electrophoresis it worked for
androbacteriaceae but also for
non-fermenting primerage of rots like
acinetobacter or pseudomonas and it may
become a new tool for detection of
viral and factors and i have to mention
that up to now the ir biotype
product and the new software is
only is research use only but
maybe that changes in the future
and with that uh i would like to thank
you very much for your
attention and uh as i've mentioned
and shown in the on the slides and the
talk i didn't do that
uh whole work alone so special thanks to
norman mauder
who is uh the guy who does all this
classifier programming
marcus uh kostroseva the head of r d uh
research
uh within brooker and miriam cordovana
who did this great salmonella
story on the ir biotype within my lab
i wanted to thank fishnikov stuff
cassin sebastian and garlina grebel and
of course also my colleague professor
irene burkhardt and many thanks also to
the national
reference lab for streptococci in achen
and also to jack rau at the lab in
stuttgart and with this final flue
on the heidelberg castle in autumn i
want to
like to thank you again for your
attention and
and this talk thank you very much
thank you dr zimmerman for your
informative presentation
so we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
could further serotypes added to the new
uh pneumococcy classifier to extend the
usage in the future
well uh we add additional strains
and capsule types of pneumococci to our
database
every week and we already
started to ask friends and cooperation
partners in europe and
israel to send us pneumococcus isolates
from their countries
to make our database more robust
robust and make sure that it
not only works let's say for german
premier cocci but it's really robust for
for global use
wonderful thank you so much now dr
zimmerman our next question
is it possible to use liquid cultures
for the r
for the ir biotyper
so in principle that should be not a
problem
so uh up to now in different experiments
we never did that but as i mentioned in
the beginning of the pneumococci story
if you standardize your protocol so if
you have the same
incubation time and always use
the same broth for for culturing
your your back of interest
then it also uh should be possible to
use liquid cultures for ir biotype
analysis
now moving on to our next question so
can an outbreak
analysis with the ir by biotyper also
work for
gram positive strains for example vres
so uh today there are already some
examples of groups that use the ir
biotyper for the analysis of
vancomycin-resistant entrococci or
of mrsa outbreaks so i'm aware of some
data of wolf schneider in reagan's book
at the
infection control department they are
doing that for vre
so this should work
okay so now our next
question which are the major benefits of
the ir biotyper
compared to classical typing methods
such as
pfge
well at least the the main advantage
in our lab is that it's less laborious
and it is much faster so
here in heidelberg we did really
pulsatile electrophoresis for
many years or let's say decades for
outbreak
analysis but the really routine protocol
we use it normally
started on monday and
gave results on on thursday afternoon on
friday so it really
took a week for days to
to get the results so uh if we nowadays
uh
are aware of uh
what's maybe an outbreak uh we uh
and we have also isolates uh already on
a blood plate let's say on a
from a vitex control blood plate
so you can directly use this if the
incubation time is the same
for the analysis and get the
results one hour later so it's it's much
faster
and less laborious and then especially
when you have uh two
or more uh outbreaks over time so for
pulsar gel electrophoresis you have to
do
a jail every time so you have your your
strains now in the uh
ir biotype database and there is a uh
another outbreak with the same bug let's
say androbacter
uh clarke or something uh similar you
just add the new isolates and and
uh can see oh this is closely related to
an outbreak we had uh
two years ago has a patient already been
in the hospital at that time
so uh there are several advantages uh
for the uh
biotype analysis compared to pfge
thank you so much for that clarification
so we do want to remind our audience
that any questions that we are unable to
answer today
and those that come in during the on
demand period will be addressed
by our speaker via the contact
information that you provided
at the time of registration so let's
move on to
our next question uh looks like this is
a
two-part question dr zimmerman so just
to clarify
ir biotyping works for mainly um
polysaccharide in the capsules of
bacteria not
protein nor lipids and if so
what happens to the non-capsulated
strains
so uh when there is
no capsule present on if it's a
non-capsulated uh pneumococcus
strain it will not cluster
to any of the uh of the capsule types we
we have in in the database and uh then
it's like a a little bit
separated cluster though it's it's not
so far away like streptococcus uh
gordonii in in the example uh i have
shown but
it's it's quite distant from from the uh
capsule bearing types and
so uh these non-capsule strains they
also
clustered together but it's of course
not
possible with our database or with our
classifier
to differentiate within this
non-encapsulated it's just
non-capsulated pneumococcal strains
great now our next question how much
time can a clinical microbiology lab
save by using the ir biotyper
versus the traditional way to tell apart
the streptococcus strains
well that depends of course of how many
uh
isolates uh you you have a per
per per week so uh
we don't have the uh so we we do the
capsule typing at the moment we plan
to uh to put it into our routine
workflow and also put the analysis uh
within our lab information system up to
now we do that for
uh isolate of specific interest so if we
have a
pediatric patient with a meningitis then
we do it for routine but
this question is really difficult to
answer because it depends how many
pneumococcus isolates or looking on
miriam's great data how many salmonella
per week
you you have to do so let's say
the national reference lab hypnococcus
say do hundreds of uh pneumococcus
capsule typings per week
we may do five to ten maybe during the
influenza season it would be some more
but
uh there is no absolute time i
i can tell you you say one hour or two
hour
depends on the amount of strains you
test per week
so our next question is it possible to
do the strain
typing analysis with the maldi maldi-tof
biotyper
or is it only possible on the ir
biotyper
well uh so i i hopefully uh
did not con confuse the audience
with showing some of our older
experiments
where we try to use the maldi uh biotype
for for for typing
and outbreak analysis which at least
worked for
gram-negative rods especially
enterobacteriac
already quite well but with all the
possibilities and classifiers we have in
within the the ir biotype software
i would recommend uh to uh
to use the uh io ir bio typer because
it's it's uh
much easier and also faster than if you
do
an outbreak analysis on the on the
multibio type because for the multi
biotyper
you have to generate uh msp so uh
own spectra for every isolate and this
took some time to to read this normally
uh overnight and then you have to
correct them and the group them
so it's less laborious and much faster
and probably with a higher
discrimination
rate if you use the i o bio type because
its software solutions are also
more specialized for for that
wonderful now does the database come
with the system or does the user need to
create their own database
well up to now
everybody has to create
it's its own databases
database so uh i'm not aware
but maybe this question could be could
be answered
by brooker said brooke is like we we
have it for the multibiotype
we were just talking about there we have
a database for
uh for uh for moles and we have a
database for microbacteria
which you buy a specific license for i'm
not aware if this
kind of databases already
are within at least not our version
but uh i think with uh some sets of
uh of uh salmonella types or
of pneumococcus will be within the new
uh ir uh biotype 3.0 software so
if you get a new instrument within very
new software version
you may have already some data sets in
it
great thank you so much so now which
other
clinical specimens can we or are we
used or processed using this new i
excuse me let me repeat that question so
which other clinical specimens can we or
are
used and pressed using this new method
with ir specs
i'm not sure if i understand the
question correct
with a clinical specimens because
what we use for for the potential caucus
and also for the salmonella
analysis also for the outbreak
analysis that i have shown
during the talk this was all from
cultured
bacteria so
looking on on the clinical specimens
where these isolates were from this work
as i've shown i think at least in the
pseudomonas
analysis that these were all kinds of
different clinical specimens like
bile tracheal aspirates blood culture
wound swabs and especially also
of course for the infection control uh
questions uh rectal swaps or
with the mrsa work for example with this
nasal swabs so
a lot of clinical specimens uh can be
used what we
haven't done yet is would be any kind of
analysis directly from the clinical
specimen so we
always worked from uh overnight cultured
bacteria
i hope this answers the question
thank you so much dr zimmerman so it
looks like we have time for one more
question
so is it possible to do to do strain
typing
based on protein molecules for example
m typing in streptococcus pyogenes
as i've shown in one of the
very first
slides uh how on the on the basics of
fourier transform infrared spectroscopy
we have these different
wave number regions or where one is for
polysaccharides one is for lipids
and we have between
1200 and 2000
nanometers of wavelength we have the
amide bonds and therefore the proteins
so if you do a specific protein analysis
you can narrow your analysis window to
this protein section
and then probably build up a database
or get some classifiers specifically for
for proteins and yes i think it should
be possible to
to also uh analyze uh streptococcus
protein regions then
wonderful so before we go i would like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr
zimmerman for his time today
and his important research we would also
like to thank lapperts and our sponsor
brooker daltonix for underwriting
today's
educational webcast you can view the
webinar on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now please join us next
week for our final broadcast of our
webinar series
utilizing rapid diagnostics and new
methods to quickly diagnose sepsis
until next time bye-bye everyone